in the midst of the coalescing and emboldening
of white supremacy, the likes of which we've
not seen for a very long time in the United
States.
Fox News propagandists Tucker Carlson is now
claiming that white supremacy fears are simply
a hoax.
Now, I don't know if he means the idea that
white supremacy exists in the United States
is a hoax.
Like as he's saying, there's not really white
supremacy or is he saying white supremacy
is real, but we shouldn't fear it?
It's not totally clear, but let's take a look
at what Tucker had to say,
but the whole thing is a lie.
If you were to assemble a list, a hierarchy
of concerns or problems this country faces,
where would white supremacy be on the list?
Right up there with Russia probably.
It's actually not a real problem in America.
The combined membership of every white supremacist
organization in this country would be able
to fit inside a college football stadium.
I mean seriously, this is a country where
the average person is getting poorer, where
the suicide rate is spiking white supremacy.
That's the problem.
This is a hoax just like the Russia hoax.
It's a conspiracy theory used to divide the
country and keep a hold on power.
That's exactly what's going on.
So this is actually, this is a combination
of what about ism and Strawmen, which are
related but not exactly the same.
Tucker first talks about the membership of
white supremacist organizations.
That's not how it works today.
Okay.
Membership organizations with tote bags and
logos and membership cards are just not the
way modern white nationalism and white supremacy
are spreading and in fact, on yesterday show
I interviewed former Neo-nazi, frank mink
and he told us when he was in the movement
when he was in the Klan in the nineties it
was about community, it was about in person
meetings.
It was about real world interaction in 2019
because of the Internet and social media that
is simply not the way that white supremacy
and white nationalism are spreading.
It doesn't matter that you're not in a official,
in an official group like when he was in the
clan with the and meetings and cookouts and
all of that stuff resembling a more formal
membership.
By definition, it is now radicalization that
is happening to people primarily through media
and they can be anywhere.
This is a total distraction.
Well, how many people are actually members
of defined and named white supremacist organizations.
It's a ridiculous Straw man.
And then Tucker says, we shouldn't be concerned
about white supremacy based on the number
of people who are members of these groups.
I wonder then if he would also say, we don't
have to be worried about Antifa because the
truth is that Antifa a group that I have never
defended is such a tiny group that it barely
exists as an organized institution and yet
Fox News and right wing media won't stop talking
about Antifa who has antifa killed and then
consider the El Paso shooter, Dylan roof,
Charlottesville and on and on and on.
When you actually look at the data, depending
on which organization's report you look at,
70 to 98% of political violence in the United
States recently is right wing.
Much of it is white supremacist, white nationalist
militia, sovereign citizen, Patriot group
type stuff.
How is that not a problem?
And then Tucker Carlson says that white supremacy
is a hoax to divide the country.
No, the white supremacy is what's dividing
the country.
This is straight up irresponsible as much
as it is untrue.
And I saw a funny comment online, white supremacists
are saying that white supremacists aren't
a problem.
This is sort of like when corporations say
corporations aren't a problem and we don't
need to regulate, they're going to take care
of themselves.
And Super Funny, by the way, renewed calls
for boycotts of Tucker Carlson's advertisers,
and I don't want to really jump into that
topic again.
I've talked before about my view on advertiser
boycotts and advertiser boycotts as a form
of speech, as a form of activism.
That's not the primary topic today, but just
by chance I saw that someone said, hey, here's
a list of Tucker's remaining advertisers.
You should boycott them.
And I looked at the list and realized that
I've sort of been boycotting all of those
companies for years anyway because they're
just terrible companies.
It's like the worst dentistry chains where
a, I won't even actually have friends who
have told me how bad they are.
Really bad dentistry chains.
I won't name them, Supplement companies, timeshare
resorts.
I don't even have to decide whether I want
to boycott Tucker Carlson's advertisers.
I've been boycotting them for years because
they're mostly scammy services and low reputation
companies at this point, which I can't imagine
is particularly good for the bottom line of
the Tucker Carlson show.
What do you think about what Tucker is saying?
White supremacy as a hoax or fears of white
supremacy as a hoax perpetrated to divide
the left, uh, to divide the rather we've talked
about real hoax is perpetrated to divide the
country.
A really good example is the entire infrastructure
that, um, uh, predicates, uh, blaming low
wages and class issues and, and issues of,
of income, uh, on Hispanic immigrants when
really it's corporations that have been distracting
us so that we don't notice.
They are the ones benefiting from that immigration.
They're the ones keeping wages stagnant.
That's a real example of a hoax specifically
meant to divide and distract Americans so
that we fight amongst ourselves instead of
realizing who's really in control.
That's a real hoax.
White supremacy as a hoax.
I don't think so.
Uh, we've got a poll about this on the David
Pakman show Instagram.
I hope you will follow it at David Pakman
show.
And while you are there, follow me at David
Dot pacman.
So two weeks ago I posted pictures of my tomato
plants.
I am doing urban gardening here in Boston.
Yesterday I posted a picture of a rabbit that
since I have built a mesh cage around my tomatoes
is furious.
The rabbit shows up every day and just stares
at my tomatoes.
The rabbit can't get in because of the Mesh
cage and the rabbit has been relegated to
eating weeds that are growing in my yard.
I put a picture of the rapid yes today on
my Instagram page at David Dot. [inaudible]
check it out.
Follow me quick break.